Consulting with Jeb to criticize that
Santa's campaign his polls are tanking
he's he's just on the fighting like I
just I I don't understand why this is
the conversation we're having I think
it's a legitimate conversation to have
should we allow or permit faked images
to be used in any sort of campaign
setting I think that's a good question
for journalism for integrity but
generally like I am tired of Republicans
by each other like just come up with
something interesting to say about
policy that's actually all I need right
now I don't care if your staffs hate
each other I don't care about any of
that because what I want is someone the
person who is leading policy
conversation for me right now is RFK Jr
and he's a Democrat so what are the
Republicans doing
more stances sure but he's a Democrat
he's not going to happen Alex and I both
had to preface we're like I swear we
love Trump yeah but yeah you know
because it's terrifying they become very
culty especially on the influencer sign
and online it's they're a little they're
a little rabid